welcome to this video playing black
against chest IPO one I guess yeah
that's the one at the end from my from
Austria right austria i went for the
English Defence again e 6 b 6 against
see for this is really an interesting
defense he went for the a39 one of the
more strategical ways to to combat that
I'm quickly going for this night
activation oh it's not developing okay
yeah I wanted to play 94 anyway bit
surprised I can yeah why not let's
attack it the queenside is weak so let's
earn a tacit you can try they are not
really thought he could maybe try quick
things some against you for take me for
24 something like that but it's not
really not really good okay now i can
there are various ideas to have to get a
good game ok let's take here first check
and now it's interesting more than one
good way to play I can um yeah come on
that's a grab a pawn take care and click
grenade this is just a double attack a
185 uh-huh Wow
now I can just take safra why not okay
he's got queen III but then I can take
before with check here okay so why not
grab this yeah no no this is not on no
yeah I can take you with check and F
Bishop c5 white resigns yeah the English
Defence or clay claims yet another
victim it's a it's really really tricky
this kind of opening especially I have
made the experience that it is
especially effective against once you
are quite often player so player 1 C
form they they like to play them there
are used schemes and ideas and they
sometimes do not adjust very well to two
original play until we solve this year
quite quickly before I think the first
step in the wrong direction when not
only for is active and d5 now as so is
the weakness after this I a five is
already really strong I think he needs
to play b5 and this is just ugly this is
probably what he needs to do
at least he's got pressure against you
seven so on I'm not sure that the move
like Bishop c5 the Sun is playable maybe
it is maybe this play ball I'm not sure
could could be an idea that's very quick
on f2 if you I don't think you can can
do something like that this looks like
it costs too much time maybe you can
hook the eight we should be for 27 yeah
very unclear that looks quite good for
black I think but difficult i played
this and this is already I think losing
check Queenie 7 is another good move
here computer points out but this is
just simple at strong winning upon to
him I can I can just take you can nick
and try and try that but i have i have
this move which is strong i can also
just just just retreat it's a pawn and
he still has got this is weird setup
yeah an opening the Duster b6 as an
interesting move against the form but
only against before it gets any other
and neither three okay um but I don't
really I don't really recommend that I
think this is just just not good or
peace or D 4b six for that matter
because of you for but on c4 you can you
can really play it but so it's a it's a
good good option alright thanks for
watching